McDonald's is under new leadership this
morning after ousting its CEO for having
a relationship with an employee Steve
Easterbrook announced yesterday he is
stepping down as chief executive of the
world's largest fast food chain and
leaving the company's board our national
correspondent tarika Duncan is here
jurika good morning so this was a
consensual relationship so what exactly
happened here it was a consensual
relationship you know both Easterbrook
and McDonald's characterized the
relationship in question as consensual
but it still violated company policy in
a statement the company said its former
CEO demonstrated poor judgment and an
email sent to McDonald's employees
Easterbrook called the relationship a
mistake and added I agree with the board
that it is time for me to move on
McDonald's saw steps toward
modernization under his watch including
expanded food delivery services and
investments in artificial intelligence
in his company-wide email Easterbrook
touted 17 consecutive quarters of growth
since he became CEO in 2015 but
international labor group fight for 15
said that tenure is blemished by 50-plus
complaints against McDonald's related to
a sexual harassment problem that company
executives have refused to address well
McDonald's previously announced a
restaurant training initiative in its
u.s. franchises to support a
professional safe and respectful
workplace it was set to begin last month
Easterbrook is succeeded by the former
president of McDonald's USA so just
another example of them you know when
you're the company you can't necessarily
have yeah relationship yeah very abrupt
arica thank you